LAWRENCE: WHO IS VLADIMIR
PUTIN OUR NEW "FOX NATION"
SHOW COHOST OF FOX AND FRIENDS
AND HOST OF "ONE NATION" BRIAN
KILMEADE THIS.
>> HE HAD A BACHELORS A GUY ON
-┘- DEGREE DECIDED TO GO INTO
INTELLIGENCE AND WENT INTO THE
KGB AND MUCH AS THE SOVIET
UNION FELL APART FROM EAST
GERMANY AND HE BASICALLY SAID
GET OFF THE WALL LET'S DIVIDE
THIS PLACE THAT THEN GO BACK
TO BEING THE SOVIET UNION AND
FROM THAT MOMENT ACCORDING TO
PEOPLE THAT KNEW HIM HE LONGED
FOR THE DAY TO PUT THIS BACK
TOGETHER.
SOMEHOW HE ENDS UP DEPUTY TO A
MAYOR THE MAYOR LOSES THE
ELECTION GOES TO MOSCOW WINS
OVER BORIS YELTSIN THEN HE GOT
INVOLVED WITH SOME CORRUPTION
MAYBE WE NEVER KNOW THE TRUE
STORY BUT THEN HE RESIGNS AND
INCOMES VLADIMIR PUTIN AND
WINS THE ELECTION AND HOLDS IT
AND HOLDS IT TO TERMS INCOMES
THEN THE HANDPICKED SUCCESSOR
MEDVEDEV AND THEN HE COMES
BACK TO HOLD THE JOB FOR
LIFE.
TALKING TO "ONE NATION"
8:00 O'CLOCK AND SAID THIS IS
NOT THE SAME GUY.
HE WAS NATIONAL SECURITY
ADVISOR TO GEORGE W. BUSH AND
HAVE THE JOB FOR YEARS A
COUPLE OF YEARS BEFORE HALLEY
TOOK OVER.
THIS IS NOT THE SAME GUY NOW
HE IS CALLING HIS OWN IF YOU
THINK OF THE BIG PICTURE WITH
THOSE HORRIBLE IMAGES OF THE
TANK RUNNING OVER CIVILIAN
VEHICLE AND THE 270 DECIBELS
THAT HAVE LOST THEIR LIVES
TODAY, HE'S TRYING TO TAKE A
COUNTRY THAT LIKES THEIR
LEADER AND WAY OF LIFE TO MAKE
IT LIKE RUSSIA THEY DON'T WANT
TO DO THAT.
EVEN IF YOU TAKE THE CAPITAL
WILL YOU HOLD 40 MILLION
PEOPLE HOSTAGE WITH YOUR INEPT
ARMED FORCES WE HAVE SEEN SO
FAR?
I DON'T THINK WE WANT -┘- IT
CAN BE DONE WE JUST SAW THAT.
LAWRENCE: YOU HAVE BEEN
STUDYING THIS GUY FOR A WHILE
SO WHAT ARE THE CHANGES THAT
WE SEE?
HIS AGE WERE HIS LEGACY?
WHAT EXACTLY IS MAKING HIM
TICK IS NOT EVEN STRATEGICALLY
THE RIGHT MOVE EVEN HIM BEING
A CRAZY GUY.
>> THE WORD IS AMONG THOSE WHO
KNOW DICTATORS THEY ON -┘- IS
WITH A SMALL GROUP AND HE SO
PARANOID ABOUT COVID-19 HE IS
AFRAID OF GETTING IT HE
ISOLATED HIMSELF EVEN FURTHER
SO I DON'T KNOW WHY BUT IT IS
A DEFENSIVE ALLIANCE THIS IS
THE FIRST TIME THEY HAVE EVEN
ARMED THEMSELVES TO PUT
THEMSELVES IN A POSITION TO
DEFEND THE NATION WE ARE IN
RIGHT NOW BUT HE SEES THIS AS
A THREAT.
HE TOOK GEORGIA NOTHING
HAPPENED HE TOOK THE REGION
AND WATCHED SHE IS WHAT
HAPPENED IN AFGHANISTAN AND
SAYS WHY DON'T I JUST TAKE
UKRAINE NOW?
GET THE CALL AND THE OIL AND
BECOME CLOSER TO THE
SUPERPOWER HE GREW UP KNOWING.
LAWRENCE: THE UKRAINIANS ARE
CRUSHING THIS MADMAN RIGHT NOW.
>> I WOULD SAY HOLDING HIM OFF
EFFECTIVELY.
BUT THE LONGER THEY HOLD THE
BETTER IT LOOKS BECAUSE THE
MORE FRUSTRATED AND
DEMORALIZED THE RUSSIAN FORCES
LOOK.
THE LONGER THEY SIT THERE AND
SAY WHY AM I DOING THIS?
I HAVE A COUSIN IN THAT TOWN.
WHY MY FIGHTING HERE?
I WAS FORCED TO SIGN UP.
I WAS DRAFTED.
RUSSIANS ARE PEOPLE TOO